Це коридори однієї з найстаріших будівель Лук’янівського СІЗО в Києві.
Цю моторошну споруду ще називають "Катя" -
на згадку про те, що будувалася тюрма ще в царські часи.
Виглядає так, ніби капітального ремонту відтоді тут не проводили.
Відчуття ніби раптом потрапив у якийсь занехаяний підвал.
Смердить затхлістю та сирістю.
Атмосфера гнітюча. Тут туляться 12 чоловіків.
Як кажуть співробітники СІЗО, площа відповідає нормі два з половиною метри на особу.
Але щодо санітарних норм - величезні питання.
Тут відсутнє свіже повітря і підвищена вологість
- ідеальні умови для поширення хвороботворних бактерій.
У нас бачите, який вентилятор. Нормальний! Замість кондиціонера. Німецький!
Чоловіки  жартують, але їм насправді не весело. Вони не хочуть, аби їх хтось упізнав.
Умови, в яких їм тепер доводиться жити, не можна назвати людськими.
Їхнє життя обмежується сидінням-лежанням на цих нарах.
Їм більше, ніж вам років.
Душ відсутній. А в таких умов розігрівають їжу.
Холодильник у нас є. Мікрохвильовка була б, якби були гроші.
Цей ремонт зроблено власними силами: тими, хто сидів і сидить.
Так, не без участі адміністрації.
Це ще не найгірша камера Лук’янівського СІЗО.
За розповідями персоналу, були часи, коли ув’язненим
через брак місця доводилося спати по черзі.
Нещодавно міністерство юстиції вигадало спосіб, як поліпшити умови перебування в СІЗО:
запровадити платні камери з поліпшеними умовами утримання,
а виручені гроші спрямувати на ремонт інших камер.
Як сказав в інтерв’ю DW міністр юстиції Денис Малюська,
це перший крок до створення в Україні приватних слідчих ізоляторів.
Подивитися, наскільки цей ринок, з одного боку, потенційно привабливий
для можливого інвестора з тим, щоб створювати приватні СІЗО.
З іншого боку, додаткове джерело коштів, щоб провести ремонт у СІЗО.
Це дасть можливість виконати рішення ЄСПЛ з приводу неналежних умов утримання.
І третє - прибрати корупцію.
Люди, які потрапляють СІЗО і при цьому мають великі фінансові ресурси,
і раніше сплачували хабарі.
Хабарі були величезними. Навіщо це толерувати, якщо можна поставити це в цивілізовані рамки?
А ось так виглядають платні камери.
Це відремонтовані кімнати, які оснастили на рівні такого собі тризіркового хостелу.
І це - наче потрапити в іншу в’язничну реальність.
Туалет, душова з гарячою водою, чайник, тостер, навіть кондиціонер, телевізор і три ліжка.
Вартість такої камери для однієї особи на місяць може складати приблизно 400 євро.
Можна платити також 2000 гривень за один день перебування в такій камері
або 8000 за тиждень.
У перші дні після відкриття кількох платних камер у Лук’янівському СІЗО
з 13-ти наявних місць одразу викупили п’ять.
Процедура така: заяву про розміщення у платній камері розглядає комісія СІЗО.
Якщо кримінальні статті ув’язнених не перешкоджають сумісному проживанню,
то особа після оплати переводиться в платну камеру.
VIP-ув’язнені не захотіли спілкуватися з нами на камеру,
але розповіли, що сидіти тут набагато комфортніше.
Утім, це обурює інших в’язнів Лук’янівського СІЗО. Вони вважають це дискримінацією.
Де вони взагалі такі ціни беруть? 12 000 на місць!!!
Покрутило їх там у міністерстві, чи що?
Це що, мої батьки, припустімо, місяць будуть працювати і всю зарплатню віддавати,
аби я сидів тут у кращих умовах? Звідки такі ціни, не можу зрозуміти!
Це що, якийсь прикол? Камера, ще й платна! Тебе посадили, а ти ще й плати!
Мені здається, їх самих треба за це посадити! Я це принципово робити не буду!
Міністерство юстиції заявляє, що гроші від платних камер
нині чи не єдиний варіант вирішення проблеми ганебних умов у СІЗО.
Безумовно, я їх розумію, що вони утримуються в поганих умовах.
Але від того, що я там не розпочну проект з платними камерами, їхні умови не поліпшаться.
Ми поступово доведемо всі камери до належного рівня.
Для цього потрібні гроші. А грошей немає.
Такий майже бізнес-підхід до роботи тюрем критикує
низка українських правозахисних організацій.
Координатор проекту "Без кордонів"  Максим Буткевич
вважає ідею міністерства абсолютно неприйнятною.
СІЗО - це місце, куди держава розміщує за рішенням судових органів людину.
І умови, в яких людина перебуває, мають відповідати певним стандартам.
Створювати ситуацію для тих, які можуть платити і мають кращі умови для перебування,
а тим, хто не може, - гірші, - це банальна дискримінація за майновою ознако.
Вона заборонена цілою низкою законів. У тому числі про попереднє ув’язнення.
І є порушенням прав людини, на мою думку.
Така фінансова дискримінація може стати приводом для нових звернень
українських ув’язнених до Європейського суду з прав людини.
У мінюсті, щоправда, з цим не згодні.
Ні. Держава в будь-який сфері забезпечує якийсь мінімально гарантований рівень.
Наприклад, мінімальна зарплата, набір медпослуг, які ви можете отримати безкоштовно.
Цей принцип працює і в СІЗО. Є базовий рівень, який надається державою безкоштовно.
Все, що вище, - за оплату.
Аргументи міністра ще більше обурюють ув’язнених.
Адже сидіти в СІЗО їм часто доводиться невиправдано довго.
То слідчі не квапляться з розслідуванням, то суди затягують з вироками.
Є навіть випадок, коли підозрюваний сидів у слідчому ізоляторі 10 років.
Я тут сиджу два з половиною роки.
Мені просто санкцію двомісячну подовжують, не можуть довести нічого.
Хай пришвидшують реформи, які змінять Кримінальний кодекс.
Тому що тут багато людей сидять за те, що, по суті,
можна було б замінити штрафами, громадськими роботами.
Цього правозахисні організації України домагаються вже роками.
Але навряд чи справа зрушить з мертвої точки, допоки не буде доведено
до кінця суддівську реформу, вважає правозахисник Буткевич.
Ми не бачимо реальних кроків. Треба оперативно, не поступаючись якістю,
розглядати справи, щоб не змушувати ще незасуджених людей,
чия вина не доведена, сидіти роками в жахливих умовах.
Треба поліпшити умови перебування. І часто це означає не просто робити ремонти камер,
а зносити теперішні СІЗО, будувати нові за абсолютно новими стандартами.
У мінюсті теж чекають на завершення суддівської реформи і готують свою
- в’язничну, яка передбачає зміну карних санкцій на більш цивілізовані,
що дозволить зменшити кількість людей у СІЗО,
а також запровадження онлайн-реєстру засуджених,
який допоможе моніторити, хто, за що і як довго сидить у СІЗО.
Наступним кроком міністр юстиції Малюська пропонує продати зайві слідчі ізолятори,
аби таким чином виручити гроші на поліпшення умов у в'язницях.
Ці законопроекти ще готуються до розгляду в Раді.
Тим часом платні камери в СІЗО вже відкрилися.
У мінюсті називають це експериментом, який триватиме два роки.
Щось схоже в Україні вже намагалися запровадити у 2003-2009 роках.
Однак тоді експеримент провалився. Через корупцію.